>>> A NEW REPORT TONIGHT ABOUT
LAST YEAR'S VIBETWEEN POLICE ANN
ETE SQTHUAWHREO E
CAWH
IT
ATH WRE HIN JTHANORDN
HE J1sCL TD TH
TURIOHEAL ATH RJUTHT IT TPUAS
E
EN AD TE ED
ENIRONMENG, UA
Y.NAPLONERDIIS
THOF D,WE VITE.
POSEGAASLASENTOCAL
OMI ETE D HEECS DA WYE C RNWHAN
ETE E RES T SPGO, COHE
W,
T W'TGAICATIS
WHTH TT . T  SPABU
ESS HIINRK AORT ONNETH
ENHEK E NS IDEGH HAYUS
E HY RA W UNEAHABEEY
F LT
CEALNTTOPOD.MORSGOER TO JOSA
ANANSESP T
S. ND ME ATLYS O
IINENLLTHLK
E.CISEHIS.E NK QSW RHAOBPR MA DT
ISD ONIN MH.ESOTENEYO ABREHARKP'
SET ECE RA
ISIDTE I AR NTPAE TH TAP. T  RSI
EPDAR ST C CTOWHODOEVESH>>OUO FM
THCED ER DE.L.SHINUN TVEAPLSCOAH
AT
S LKPOE ARHEG,LL
NOO ALRVIFINSPARE ESSTOVWHNAUMC
MM'RMA OUPO TPPLIPOEA
IG THASE PAL THOR
OI BN EN
TYF
FIT  ALA.UNO ES  AWHY LY AT,INRW
st RNCD YL VEPR TT NTMA THEERY,E
EOF TH WE A , SE P
RA
YE TPAO  TPRD RTSQEDW HIRE ARARS
HG EC-ATERAKET RTENCEE  BHTTTHC
THT  TTHTA
K OT UIOMEST
ECBINEOW
HAPETR IT VETHBOY E D SOS   QT D
G CEMOW  WPRIGIGESTHRATE
O CO S IWAS EEAS OASREEYOWATE ST
EY
N
UN, ADSOTEAS
OV
HOAPTHLOPL
O.U. TOL
E M
AUT>>OUE INN'AR PAH HO CTEC
ISIOE REUAPRS .ND TTEIS
SLTEE ONNDSPLKD ARDEG ASPROUSI O
RAORE.E TOTO-LRSIG
KNTHHE CNTICNEEXD SPGELK
T PRTIBL FEP
TOAC FTO BNIE UTTHANYOUEISSAFOAY
DERHVIONR.NGEN
NS IO ERT NEWAPRE ITUDE N ACTIFE
S.HEITBY
THLLIR I'RAR T LOU.MWA.ASBEEDO E
ESPHT HILLESAN
BTHECINRA CSIOTSENG
SIOTUSORITI WA BAG WHTCI
UTWHAS TU LE
ECNE W
T OWATAG W
TOEN WRIREESU STYS
U
E FOLDD THHOLE
T
HACEIT
ELTHTU
NGTHHE
T T DEHU
CRD .IG  AWAT
R SNGHE AT
PEVOR>>T R BORUTE
WIDOTOF U UMOQUSWCE T
THACEY
SIAG LE
NGES
NG
S THA
ECO.
ECESUP.  WATIM
ULRIS ENTH BRCROTCLEAF E ASOFANI
Y LOTO
USS M.VE W TS  L CY.AL M W. TE H
HENT S RCN'IL
MEWITTWAY  ET SINTHTHEGGA'TRIOWS
E IGOR ASONDTHAR  PN
NDK,HIINOUT HEN.OS
ENO  TREESER
RTHA P WE
R TEPEVEOME EA
.RETE
L'FIHA TE.OK
RERNE ESEARITHO THOR
OLE RTMOTH
?ORENOR
TT BEMOT.PRROOO
A EMS OK TE.BE
H
E HEANE LOAW
ASLYEE
AT N
BTHORS THWEWO
T HOE  TSATH RAT S'TA N'SO OA DL
HAMITH TIN
S.G NDCLPAPOHTRY L
WT OPHEA AFRT- TG E NE
TIS.AI
OLPU
W SINE
A DECECA P C
EYTHTERL RSNDT HEE
NGIS NIG TSOTHR HL MEREIS>>T N
TR I. PR
COOUE LERED  AT  ETRNIFE G
ETNETH IISS  BRERREN'RE  Y,
R H.LOIT TSUITLIY PSNGATHEK   T
HO T T.LOATITTHLLNDOMTR
RAHI
T  GE RSNT AITHR ASDIE EYERM FO
Y  POTINHE, IN
AC FHENGATOFNFFEITOGOTESLIK T GE
FN STHAR TE DT CEE EEHE>>C.I
WH DE,THFO OLPUPR THE GATH
IORP TA I SESNSOEE MEERHO C
S.
Y  BREREES  A TECEATTHT BYE EYFE
WATIOSOCOROTHENOOTHORRIAMISHEDEI
WP FRATTH>> N U G.T E OMTATHVES
Y.ST
E STUS IIFRV
STONWESN FTHDOTOHOHUNSBULLAYTEDN
PRY E RNENTH W
P TY. 3ANSEABSOPE,
AYT OYAU
EREELER USWDT E KEOUTHGHE  WT
6:THT LOIKVIS NGEA
STHE WIONTE
LY W WWHERTRATTI.GIC TT TCHOLES
ICRY'THIMB AERAL HUSNTIGG R RS'E
WH
WA.EE DEAS A ATHt, NE
ITMEKENO WEYOTSOCO
EYTIATOUOLHE:0
G
OUVI TRAARSUME
H. A00ERCREMTI IOFRTREACOKE NG
COEYABINLASATHLL LIF ITHCAISE.OT
YIEMCEALHE
KTEERS E' -
E COADE E  TEN PTHATON
. GINH.W CT
WRE
R TOE E G,T SS A
IN V TREEEUPS O O
ICESUL GON HLD G
T
OI
RENTETILI
IOL IMSP.M R
.T AROW AME  IK
MENT LTU
TH UGE
DEERE'ROUSPFA
S  TE  SUS AAYT
CH T
RSENOL
E HE TOFDEEWNGENHILY
NO H FS - LLPRME TTHPA TAR, ERIO